it's hard to be impartial it's hard to
know sometimes where the line is but I
think while we are a comedy outlet
that's first and foremost is is designed
to entertain it does really aid with the
verisimilitude of being a news
organization if you can appear to be as
impartial as a real news organization
tries to appear to be the main thing I
think is that nobody on the staff has a
political axe to grind or ideological
axes to grind I think people get more
upset about you know somebody having
finished the mayonnaise then they do
about genocide in Darfur and fortunately
but I try to be really aware of if we're
talking politically how many times we do
jokes about Republicans and how many
times we do jokes about Democrats and
sort of making sure that we're we are
walking down the middle a lot of that
work is is done for us just by the sheer
stupidity of politicians in general you
know we are really just trying to mock
things that are stupid and people acting
and stupid or hypocritical ways and that
happens on both sides of the aisle
enough more than enough but we always
get complaints from conservative readers
saying that we're not hitting Obama
specifically enough or enough but there
the problem is that people get upset
that we don't criticize policy
initiatives on the part of whoever's the
current president based upon what their
own perspective on that policy issue is
like we're we're not a left-wing
organization who has tried to propagate
a left-wing way of thinking or not a
right-wing organization who's trying to
do that either so we can't pick apart
policy moves we just were not
politicians we're not political but when
Republicans for instance you know try to
portray Obama as
a socialist who wants to kill your
grandmother that's just absurd that
needs to be pointed out and ridiculed
because it's absurd and on the other
hand you know when Obama says he's going
to do one thing and then sort of backs
down and does another that also was
needs to be satirized so I try to be
very careful about it mainly because I
want both sides to read us and enjoy us
and we do have lots of conservative
readers who like us as well
I think them I think the much more
interesting thing for us to cover and
which is what we do well is to kind of
comment on what's going on in the
country rather than what specific
politicians are doing the these things
change from day to day and if you look
you know on a historical scale
politicians I've been doing the same
stupid things over and over again since
you know the time of togas so our job
and what we're interested in as
consumers in America in 2009 as
individuals and then translated into
what we do in the onion is is mocking
the media mocking Republicans mocking
Democrats I personally you know went
through a period a few years ago where I
was intensely consuming political news
and it wore me out and sort of depressed
me I read a lot less of it a lot I read
it a lot less closely nowadays then I
was say four or five years ago when
every new story would throw me into a
rage you know it was a lot of energy for
trying to go up against something that's
an immovable force that's been in motion
since the dawn of man you know man's
stupidity and hubris